like that sometimes I'll put it right
here boom boom and sometimes I'll squirt
here yeah I was stupid that was stupid
you should cut that out
hey everybody I'm Charles Melton and
these are my essentials I was born in
Juneau Alaska lived there with in
Kentucky Tennessee Georgia Texas Killeen
Texas Seoul South Korea
it was shine Germany Manhattan Kansas
New York Los Angeles is now Vancouver
Korea for sure Wow
Korean barbecue trained karaoke my
family's there so it's really good
first up my Angela my lover she's a poet
she has beautiful poems I gave this with
me everywhere and just randomly opening
it up if you know that youth is dying on
the run and my daughter trades dope
stories with your son we'd better see
what all our fearing and our jeering and
our crying and our line brought about
take time out my Angela I'm an avid
reader for poetry I read poetry often
and I write for the tree as well
[Music]
so I have a lot of these notebooks I
carry them with me I can put them in a
pocket to the dress shirt my back pocket
just doing a lot of writing random
writing different colors feelings
letters to people goals and all that
stuff I love writing letters I still
write letters actually write letters to
my girlfriend and my family
just something special about someone
opening up a letter you know cuz today
everyone's texting sending emails
calling FaceTime every there's something
special with weathers it's like a lost
art form I do that headphones these are
essential
these are noise counselling Bose
headphones and I take these every with
me to be honest I only I work out in
these I fly with these but I prefer the
iPhone headphones the court just when
I'm talking to people with Eric Conn's I
don't know they're I don't
not a fan a lot of Frank Ocean I'm
listening to a lot of Frank Ocean right
now and sticky fingers sticky fingers is
really good
[Music]
this isn't essential YSL there's a why
it smells good
just one Scott okay it smells good you
likes it I get a lot of compliments
wearing this this is an essential I take
this with me everywhere I love this I
brush my hair with this and it's great I
usually make my hair with my hands but
there's just something special about
this brush it is a Mason Pearson brush
love it it's great I usually brush my
hair in the shower that's it you just
brush it in the shower put conditioner
and shampoo in just brush it
I think mention investing that taking
care of themselves but not to overdo it
the foam roller and essential especially
traveling this is works out the knots
and the lactic acid I really want this
it's a good stress reliever
I'm proactive within this I'm gonna that
former athlete I played football at
Kansas State for Bill Snyder so I played
safety can this hold me hopefully this
doesn't break and I just just roll out
and it's like massaging the muscles
outside of my spine it feels really nice
well this is a back brace it helps with
your posture it's an essential I'm a
sloucher I just got this I put it on
when I'm bored you just slip it on
look at his posture it's good just
searching and seeing good deals online
this was a impulse by pop socket this is
great I can touch your hand take a look
at the film like this like this send it
like this pop socket I think everyone
should have a pop socket I should invest
in that I would put maybe a picture of
my mother you know I'll just keep it
black I like it's just a simple and
clean KC head I just love this that
reminds me of home I'm from Mahan Kansas
and she's just cool hat I have a red one
different style cap and then I have a
black one back home but this is my most
recent I've had this for a few years I
don't know he's wear hats but when I do
came to see the shades I love these
shades man you can wear indoors outdoors
I like these pair of glasses because of
the style and simple the tint the lens
of the color of the lens let's kind of
go a retro vibe to it you know kind of
you know jumps up the swag a little bits
a little swaggy so well that was it guys
those were my essentials make sure you
brush your hair wear your Cologne work
on your posture and stay out of trouble
which left I'm out peace
[Music]